hey leute hier ist wieder eure mal wanne
und ich bin wieder zurück ist rennt weg
ja ich war im urlaub sieht man das denn
meego ja wow du siehst gut aus nicht wie
bitte nicht ich meine nicht gut
also war ich du bist wieder zurück genau
und als ich weg war habe ich viel über
etwas nachgedacht sie hört auf mit
youtube wetten
ich höre doch nicht auf aber jetzt wo
wir darüber im video gesprochen haben
könnte ich es als titel benutzen so
viele youtube haben das schon gemacht
die nummer zieht einfach nicht mehr oder
tschuldigung wolltest du nicht sagen wo
wir nach gedacht hast genau das wollte
ich tun denn da ein oder andere weiß es
vielleicht schon das mit meinen augen
etwas nicht stimmt und zwar habe ich
grünen star duo arme warte mal wenn du
das heißt dann haben wir das ja auch
könnt eigentlich auch so ein geiler rap
aktiva name sein grüner starker und
jetzt mal spaß beiseite es ist ziemlich
karg achtung wer nicht weiß was das ist
wird jetzt etwas neues lernen bereitet
euer gehirn schon mal darauf vor
das ist ein auge und in dem auge gibt es
eine kammer flüssigkeit wenn die nicht
richtig abläuft ist dein augeninnendruck
sehr hoch und dann hast du grün start
der hohe druck im auge sorgt dafür dass
deine sehnerven bestätigt werden wenn
deine sehnerven kaputt sind
dann bist du irgendwann blind ende und
wie kann man jetzt diesen grünen star
behandeln fast gar nicht ich bekomme
zwar schon augentropfen die den
augendruck niedrig halten soll
aber was bis dahin kaputt gegangen ist
das wird niemals wieder kommen außer ihr
kennt jemanden der jemanden kennt der
jemanden kennt der gleichen werkstatt
hat in den eher weil sie nicht sehnerven
produziert dann ruft mich an so
langweilige geschichte
ich erzähle euch nicht davon weil ich
mitleid erhaschen möchte die mitleids
krabbe mitleid mitleid mit mitleid mit
er als entschuldigung dafür dass ich
manchmal nicht ganz so produktiv bin ich
habe das thema so lange heruntergespielt
und immer gesagt ist es nicht voll
schwerer mit zu legia es gibt menschen
ihr menschen die haben eine schlimme
krankheit und es ist okay ich habe die
diagnose mit 18 bekommen und leider
waren bis dabei meine sehnerven schon
ziemlich nah jah kaputt caputh iwf in
die sind kaputt die augentropfen jeden
abend zu benutzen ist gar nicht so
schlimm denn sie haben nur eine
nebenwirkung die wimpern verlängern sich
das schlimmste was diese 1 krankheit mit
sich gebracht hat ist mein
empfindlichkeit von licht her
das problem bei lichtes aber das ist
einfach über alles und ich immer auf die
hier angewiesen bin
oh je die übersetzt ich trage meine
sonnenbrille ab dem moment ab daems
aufstehe und setzte sie erst wieder ab
wenn die sonne untergeht die einzige
ausnahme bei der ich keine sondern trage
ist wenn ich videos drehen
es heißt wenn wieder alle im winter ab
kotzen dass die tage so kurz sind dann
fängt meine zeit an ge um 16 uhr 17 uhr
18 uhr runter keine sonderrolle für
vanessa andererseits ist es schon wieder
kacke dann wenn es schneit und ich mit
sonnenbrille ein schneemann bau sieht
das einfach immer aus was würde
passieren wenn ich die sonnenbrillen
nicht tragen würde dann würde ich so
ungefähr dreimal die woche mit einer
migräne flach liegen vor ungefähr vier
jahren war es nämlich noch so da hatte
ich ständig migräne ich lag ständig
flach jetzt wo ich weiß dass
lichtempfindlichkeit und kräne so eine
verbindung zueinander hat da ist es
nicht mehr so schlimm ich habe jetzt so
alle zwei monate eine migräne dann aber
auch so richtig schön mit kotzen und
packen kopfschmerzen tod leider ist die
migräne nicht das einzige was finster
lichtempfindlichkeit bekomme denn
manchmal kann ich zum beispiel nicht
lesen nicht weil ich analphabet bin
sondern weil diese kleinen schwarzen
buchstaben auf einem weißen hintergrund
anfangen zu flackern und ich kann mich
auch kein wort konzentrieren das ist
übrigens auch so wenn ich dann auf dem
computer was lese oder auf meinem handy
was lese an manchen tagen sind meine
augen so richtig kommt zurück zum punkt
also wenn mal keine videos kommen oder
sie seltener
band einfach daran dass wir menschen
sind und keine maschine ruby hallo leute
hier ist wieder eure mal wanne
auch wenn es youtuber gibt die ganz
viele ganz tolle videos produzieren
juli dann heißt es nicht dass jeder so
funktioniert und mal ganz ehrlich wer
möchte schon funktionieren wir wollen
leben und uns nicht stressen lassen und
ihr solltet es auch tun
namaste meine kinder